hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to doom internal we
just got done doing whatever the hell
that was absolutely destroying everybody
inside of it now we got to get over to
his escape pond so that we can get out
of here and continue our journey to the
center of Mars through the hole that I
created but I'm not bitter about it and
I'm not gonna keep harping about it
because at the end of the day there's a
big old hole in the middle of Mars I
don't know why do you that's a good
question alright you think I would have
just been able to can myself straight
into Mars why did I have to make the
intermediary step here great from what
it's not like there's any atmosphere
apparently there's atmosphere I see
you're a buddy oh here I am what you're
telling me that I landed on the
outskirts and not in the dead center oh
no I'm exactly where I need to be oh
[Music]
very fascinating kaboom oh hi thanks for
the Sentinel battery that's awfully nice
of you good to have that just lazing
about glad you know that you don't need
to hide him from me anymore
alright the lost city of Hobart admits
the long and enduring history of
Sentinel civilization there are moments
in antiquity that have become buried in
time forgotten chapters that remain
concealed the seminal historians waiting
to be unearthed the Fallen city of her
birth is one such tale all but forgotten
to the tones of legacies past once a
prosperous port city a proud gleaming
marker of conquest for the distant tribe
of Athene clansmen of the outer world
Herr Beth bridged the disparate Sentinel
cities with the indigenous design of a
Slipgate invention but it was not meant
to last and among those cities lost in
the Crusades of Sentinel past was her
bath now little more than a smoldering
ruin swallowed by the quaking surface of
a once habitable Mars well alright then
man they really love the solar system
here they had a lot of stuff doing well
hi I hear a lot of goings ons in there
what's that all about anything I should
know about
also this chapter has been long hey bad
point hey bot point ever blink ever
boink boink bad boy
man you guys are in a tizzy well don't
mind me getting in the way of good time
I
got
Oh No Oh No
ah your big brother was not able to put
up much of a fight so I don't know what
you're gonna be able to do a whole lot
of nothing actually it's weird what I
thought that it would have been a little
bit more considerable all things can sit
well that's embarrassing thank you I
need this whoa hey bud how you doing
good see it your of it you're a bit
quicker
I mean God that arm
well that was dumb hey but it works
hey now you're doomed I recommend
and oh sorry kablooey boom sorry I
leveled up I'm doom level 8 oh yeah oh
and that was the last of it how good is
that buff camo look too bad there's
nothing left of well yes there is more
more please
more please more please more more MORE
oh that's satisfying that's really nice
that's the good stuff you tell me this
stuff has survived for a thousand
thousand years and it's blown up now
just because I put a little hole in the
planet what a baby what a bunch of
babies so how did they get them there
that's the big question how did how did
they transport it all the way over
yonder way because this seems like hard
to get to you alright whatever
thanks Hayden you too man well not
anymore but you too robot nice yeah I
didn't do the challenges I know I know I
know I didn't even know I was supposed
to do that for some reason I guess I was
just killing the manky by by just
slapping him no I was one away from
right whatever I got these which is
really what matters that's the good
stuff that's what they call the good
stuff you've traveled through the core
of Mars arriving at the ancient city of
Sentinel Prime you have sovereignty in
this unholy place for now the great
Slayer was once a warrior king in this
world tradition grants you safe passage
but the completion of your mission will
come at a price he'll priest Groff is
waiting all right well waiting to die
hey
so I would do what was that birthday
what do you say interesting
Great Slave or the priest
okay you guys like my armor it's classic
well eliminate Deidre Grove so this
entire level is just on one boss fight
hell yeah hell yeah oh hell yeah oh nice
feels very like God of War just in the
environment just cuz it's so much that's
a lot of D Moo's oh my goodness love the
music - oh that's some good stuff
Sentinel Prime the ancient arena is a
holy place for the people of Argentina
or constructed in the earliest days of
their history this Colosseum served as a
proving ground for trial by combat
historical records indicate that the
Argenta did not jail their own kind
rather prisoners and criminals were
granted the right to earn their chance
at regaining honour through victory in
the arena those who succeeded were given
a place to fight in the front lines of
the Sentinel army to die in service of
argent the Miller this tradition use of
the arena has subsided since the
assimilation with the dark realm the
corrupted priests now allow more violent
exchanges with armed captives pitted
against demons for sport the priests of
the order D continue to hold undisputed
power on argent DeNooyer spilling the
blood of the art and ascended class will
result in the transgressors banishment
asylum amongst the Argenta will be
denied to any who do not adhere to the
rules of engagement well I'm about to
screw all over those rules hey it's the
same tech as my ship Wow
wowie wowie I'm imagining that there's
going to put me through a big ol arena
what the hell hi hello are you the two
priests I killed just outside the castle
walls he was badly wounded and wearing
this huge guts kill them must kill them
all
he has fight in him yet in spite of his
injuries send him to the arena
let him be judged like the others so
this is the doom guy from the original
doom that has a ton of implications and
I think it futs is with the timeline a
lot and I don't think it was necessary I
feel like there's a lot of times when a
story going into the sequel what they do
is they go for the backstory route and
it's a classic way to go and now I'm not
criticizing it a lot because just
thinking about that puts a smile on my
face but also it complicates what could
be a very simple character and
simplicity does not mean bad character
simple characters just if a character is
all what he needs to be he or she if
it's all what it needs to be then at all
what it is and if people embrace the
characters anyway then there's good not
everything needs a justification or if
it does need justification he needs only
as much justification as it deserves let
other people fill in the gaps now that
being said still puts a smile on my face
little hokey with the whole goods huge
guts it really solidified that this is
not only the guy from the original doom
this is the guy from that doom comic
where he was like her guts huge guts rip
and dare rip and dare that's uh that's
really funny
I like that I like that anyway can I
have all this armor epic
why am I not putting that on my body
there's a lot of history in this room I
bet I bet I wonder if anyone's able to
actually decipher this language it would
not be surprised if that was actually
some kind of pseudo language that they
made oh okay why I don't trust you but
why okay
oh I wasn't reading the history of the
sentinels what I Oh
oh I did the time of grief Sheen came
the makers Argenta brought a newfound
clarity I did read that in the time of
king Novak did I read this one he was
not of our world and spoke an ugly
tongue how he first took step upon our
land was unknown said no Scouts had
found the Outlander bloodied clawed and
near death mumbling of impending doom in
the forces of darkness the scent of
blood followed him and the gore that
stained his armor seemed not entirely
his own by our gentle law the stranger
would be judged in the Coliseum where we
would be given a chance of all who stray
from the path to fight for his freedom
we knew not of this stranger his mind
seemed crippled with rage he dressed in
a tire not suited for our lands and
carried munition of arcane origin we
watched as his will overcame his
injuries and in the blood arena he
proved his worth the Outlanders
technique was crude and brutal but the
determination in his charge echoed that
of any true born Sentinel his war cry
echoed through the Coliseum as did the
sound of his fury and the guards cheered
his banner rip and tear they shouted as
the beasts push beyond mortal wounds and
certain death he would be gifted no rank
no title the survivors in the arena were
provided only one reward the right to
earn an honorable death while spreading
the blessing of the makers to those in
need the outlandish determination was
witnessed his ravings documented and
through the word of the order deed the
con maker had him brought before her she
said her minions - learning his tongue
for with his ugly words he spoke of
lands unseen creatures born of fire and
a
Darkplace unknown to the Queen and her
cast yet another opportunity to expand
the gift of the makers to those in need
on the eve of the Black Star the Dark
One's came from a world beneath our own
not through ship nor ephemeral vessel
but through the fabric of dimensions out
of swirling fiery gates came horned
beasts from a timeless realm first one
than many crashing waves of evil swelled
from the Obsidian forests of the
Argentine Overland's the allure
implanter me stern mountains fell first
to the black hordes of devils and the
city of de lorem was slung under the
weight of their charge
we sentinels rose to meet the beasts
with spear in hand the might of the holy
fleet striking back at the demons but
the dark gates from whence they came
gave birth still to even greater hordes
a line of blood was drawn with the
fallen of both sides and the unholy wars
began as the time of darkness came upon
us this is really getting complicated in
the storyline which is interesting no
I'm not [ __ ] on it I swear I'm not
I shan't be [ __ ] on it I wouldn't
dare
how is in the ever it's getting a little
convoluted a lot of history here a lot
of lore all this universe building it's
much more a mixture of fantasy for
and so I give it to them
if you let the priest live then I will
return to you
what the demons took from you so you
mean my pet rabbit all right sure sweet
all right let's do this how do I go back
whoo how did I miss that Arbor nailed it
I'm out see you around buddy all right
turning back getting out of here getting
what I got back oh well I'm trying to
know who skipped Emmylou okay well I
guess it wasn't actually a choice then I
guess it was all an illusion and I
didn't actually get a chance to get what
I lost back Oh interesting
seems like you offered me something but
you didn't give me a chance to do it
maybe go out this way no can't do that
well I guess not
what's all this then hello hello
history of the Sentinels part 7 where's
part 6 I literally just got part 5
that's weird the con maker demanded a
tithe of the essence the essence what is
the essence I don't know what that is
where's the other codex
oh right there interesting all right
here we go
unlike enemies of the past we could not
contain the demons emerging from the
dark realm the weaponry was not conjured
from machine steel but from the essence
of their being a dark magic not known to
us in many of our conquests had we grown
overconfident our victories serving to
dull our blade as we drank in the glory
of our expanding Empire lost we knew not
have how to prevail against this foe the
maker God stood perplexed and our
engineers and priests scrambled to find
the advantage in battle we so
desperately needed
unknown to the enemy we were pushed to
the brink of defeat and her god stood
with us as we work to find the answer
the order of the digue were the first to
unlock the mystery of these foul
creatures the priests were able to
capture several the beasts and set about
to identify the source of their power it
was then that the essence of the dark
realm was discovered not wholly unlike
our own this power was the life essence
that flowed through their twisted form
and powered their attacks it could be
harnessed to power our own weapons
giving the Argenta the chance to combat
the demons on even footing the priests
believed that with greater knowledge of
the essence we could discover its source
and cut it off from the demons to
strangle their armies from within
allowing us to regain the advantage we
required for victory on the battlefield
the Khan maker gave blessings to our
majesty and directed the priests to
delve deeper into the mysteries of the
scarlet elixir from the demonic realm
for she sought only to return balance to
our universe proper assimilation was
required as hell stood beyond her
influence after great effort the priests
discovered more than they had ever hoped
for they learned of the true nature of
the demonic energy and how it could
strengthen those skilled enough to
harness its power the energy coursing
through the malformed bodies of our
relentless enemy could be used to end
life or enhance it the power to heal two
men immortality knowledge and
enlightened faculties beyond our
understanding with the demons lifeforce
in the skilled hands of the Sentinel
priests and under the righteous gaze of
the con maker our people would not only
rise to victory over the unholy horde
that clawed at our walls we would move
to a higher plateau of existence
assuring in a new era of military
science and industrial healing no
Sentinel would grow sick no maker would
need to suffer the Transfiguration that
they so feared all would be risen none
could ever oppose our pea
four ways and threaten our world again
true balance over hell and it's legions
over space and time in this world and
all others we would dictate the order
United with the makers we would find
peace eternal all of that picture
that's so dopey let's really dopey
that's a little dopey all right
the con maker demanded a tithe of the
essence and driven by her desire the
priest submitted themselves to her will
the order of the deep took counsel with
the king speaking only of the spoiled
lands sure to be found through the cleft
in creation and the opportunity to purge
the new invaders from our to denooyer we
took the war to their cursed land
pressing through the gates of wizardry
it was one among us who seemed to know
the true nature of these foul demons it
was the Outlander the stranger who had
come to us from places unknown he who
had survived in the frontlines far
longer than any Sentinel born prisoner
had before his passion for battle
against the vile horde was evident his
lust for their destruction matching our
own though our jinda nor remained a
foreign land to him his fervor caught
the attention of inquisitors of the
sentinel guard some whispering of a
suspected allegiance he held in secret
with the demons silencing the critics
King Novick deemed him worthy of
selection the signifiers brought a
commission to our king and it was
decided that he be lifted from the
common rabble though no arena born
prisoner had ever been granted the honor
the night sentinels broke tradition and
deemed the Outlander worthy of training
a number of disciples grumbled and
chafed
the barbarian present in their ranks but
in the war with the demons all
opportunities for even the slightest
advantage was to be considered and as
they witnessed the stranger spar with
their Hall masters they found him in an
undying unrelenting compatriot this man
was an outsider friend to none and yet
Rose each time he was thrown to the dirt
of the circle battered and bruised his
brow stained with blood he rose with
grim
nation for the chance to face his
enemies in armed combat once again time
passed as the stranger was instructed in
the Kahn defied matrices of their order
the ancient lessons of battle and
brotherhood taught to all sentinels he
could sense the opportunity before him
soon all of hell would feel his wrath
once again satisfied that he would not
be a detriment to their prowess the
night sentinels granted him his wish
as they ventured through the hell gates
with this stranger in tow they knew no
rest fighting in the unnatural elements
and training under the blood moon of
night the stranger suffered exhaustion
wounds and sickness but asked for no aid
and was offered none three times the
night sentinels ventured into the gate
and back and upon every returned the
stranger strode more capable than before
his gate locked in step with the march
of the sentinels a disciplined and now
controlled lust for demon blood
ever-present the passing of years in the
numerous battles with the devil's
indentured the stranger d'argent as
mightiest warriors and no longer did
they condescend to him as a new blooded
conscript for to them he had become a
brother-in-arms forged in war an ally
and a weapon that was a mouthful where
am i oh I have no idea what was I doing
I again I have no idea I was going up
that way
is there anything up this way other than
that button button
ooh not very secretive but I'll take it
what up thank you was that it yeah it
doesn't seem like anything else is
yourself why not ooh do I get a map yes
I do interesting so I'm wondering where
the in the last game there was all this
lore about how there was a betrayal and
all the people of Argentine or I thought
were killed I thought I suspected but
maybe I was wrong
see that's the thing in the last game
like the lore was like a back piece to a
lot of the gameplay which was just a
stop this from happening it was
important it was the motivation of why
it was all happening in the first place
but it was all background to the main
point of just kill demons period there
is no rest there never will be what do
we got here oh that's cute that's cute
as we Ward with the Beast the argenta
society grew under the watchful eye of
the makers and through the endless power
of the essence
while our generals were consumed with
the unholy war our culture was marked by
the beautiful potion the enemy had
provided us the sweet elixir it brought
us immeasurable capacity and empowered
us to reach farther into dimensions once
thought to be beyond our grasp under the
direction of our maker gods in the
engineering of a high priests a weapons
blazed at our war machines
stormed the throngs of the populace
drank deeply from the well of energy
unveiled by the priests a we of the
Nights sentinels took no part in their
abundance some among us whispered
accusations and warnings against this
manner of
progress but they were quelled as it was
not our role to dictate the future of
our people only descended that seems
illogical considering that the king is
only of the warrior class and the
Sentinels see there's a problem with
adding Laura's like every time you do it
raises up questions and that's what
that's what people do that's what fans
do they fill in the gaps and anytime
there is a gap like there's this like
urge to fill it because I thought this
is a society based on the strongest rule
and given that the strongest is probably
from the Knights sentinels and I the
king would have an idea of what to do I
mean again there are this god I guess
hard to defy them if that was all as
part of that I don't know I'm just
trying to piece it together as I go
along who dad me Wow wowie wowie alright
as the black star ascended to its zenith
King Novak's at Restless on his throne
as a howling darkness began to assemble
just beyond the mountain rise to the
east the blight came upon us in droves
flooding forth from the Hell Gate with
merciless fury they brought with them a
monstrous tightened the dread not a
beast to rival the stature and Menace of
even the mightiest ancestral the
grotesque giant laid waste to all before
him crushing all in his path this was a
total demonic assault striking at the
heart of Archon DeNooyer as never before
how was it that this behemoth could pass
with a demonic gate without warning we
would never know though the night Santa
knows believed treason was at play
caught off guard the Sentinels scrambled
late in defiance of the Titan and his
horde and with his coming the holy city
of Terrace Nevada prepared for judgement
with the onslaught of demons masked in
the sprawling shadow of the abhorrent
fiend the city shook to its foundations
none were spared save those that fled
north the vile swarm ransacked our
temples and palaces burning our towers
and feasting on the souls of our clergy
yet the night sentinels rally then held
fast against the demon
though they were pushed back and
corralled that the blood rena as the
dark of night descended their swords
remained potent and shred the enemy
multitude with abandoned amidst the
unyielding ranks of the Sentinels when
all other apprentices had fought in
battle stood the Outlander rip and tear
he roared ferocious in battle the
remaining conscripts of the arena stood
in awe as they witnessed the beast who
had once traje dwith in their very cells
now armored alongside the shoulders of
his sentinel brethren he had risen when
none other had before
a true worn Sentinel fighter the very
best among them but though the swarm
fell before their assault the tightened
remained invincible for none contained
the behemoths alone in the hours before
dawn as the night sentinels weathered
the relentless assault
the Outlander held his ground at the
foot of the great wall in the northern
bend of the castle seeing his unending
vigor
samer some more Sam your Chancellor to
the mother God hurried the Outlander
away under veil of secrecy and for
reason unknown submitted him to a rite
untold
this was heresy for Sam Moore received
no consent from the Khan maker nor did
he receive her counsel in the Chapel of
purity the Outlander submitted himself
to the divinity machine there some more
maker the Seraphim known to us only as
the aid to the mother God blessed the
Outlander with fierce speed and power to
match his will it was the method by
which his transfusion took place that
was most uncertain to us for we were of
the knowledge that the maker device
bestowed onto the Argenta so many
generations ago was to be used by the
priests only to find the impurity among
us how could it be that the device that
was meant to call the Sentinel breed of
its contaminants could then be used to
purify the Outlanders body and give rise
to the one who would lead us into battle
hence force what rose from the holy
coffin on that fateful day was not
pure abomination the Covenant warned of
us the hero within would come to be
known only as the great slayer the time
Walker the warrior Khan whose fire sword
would blaze forth the path for the just
and cut through the demonic horde with a
vengeance that only a god king could
summon heroes unbroken by the ritual his
eyes burning with Maker magic
he took the crucible in his hand and
Wraith fire left forth from the blade as
only it will when beheld by a true
Sentinel warrior king except Samuel
Hayden turned it on in the first game in
our darkest hour the Slayer had been
chosen defying tradition our most sacred
laws in the will of the Great Khan
herself a stranger to our lands had been
blessed with celestial might okay okay
okay all right
I accept that I accept it that's what
the people in the game have written and
so that's what they want the story to be
and my misgivings about that which I
have shall go unspoken for now because I
want to get back to the killing and it's
been about thirty minutes since I killed
anything and I am you know itching for a
kill so I'm gonna go kill something am I
going to kill anything
we can sold and the energy will continue
to flow it is your people to survive
so I have another question who is
leading hell who are the leaders of hell
if your leader of both this place who
leads hell who are their leaders cuz I
think in the first game and alluded to
their being leaders over there unless it
is just a mindless horde which is fine
but why would they do what you want them
to do but I wanna kill something and
that oh here we go more reading Oh Dee
Grove okay he grabbed remains the most
powerful to help priests amongst the
people of our tintin or frequently
visiting his ancient world the Lord over
the populous arrogant and pompous grab
calls for bloodsport in the arena to
entertain the fallen citizens of
Sentinel Prime since the demonic
invasion of Earth began he has operated
on the plant surface along with his
fellow help restore direct health forces
and after the deaths of deke nighlok's
and agura knock his fled to the safety
of the arena
it was Dee grab a facility at the
tournament and eventual betrayal of the
Sentinel commander Valen taking the keys
to the sepulchers of elements and
opening the vault of the sleeping Ray's
ancient creatures were abducted
transported hel and tortured to siphon
away their power or he used the heart of
Valens son to animate the icon of sin a
Titan still a spoken of in legend
throughout argent DeNooyer huh then I
bet Sentinel commander Valen would
really want vengeance like an eternal
quest for vengeance of unstoppable
bridled rage and maybe as penance for
his punishment he would be bestowed upon
glorious powers by the last remnants of
these people so that he may avenge the
entire race that was cleansed because of
his mistake so his eternity in conquest
is both a quest for vengeance and a
sentence in Hell where he may
perpetually fight against the demon
hordes as his rage consumes hims until
he knows nothing but the burning lust
for demon blood that's what I would do
if I made a mistake that grievous I want
to kill something I want to kill
something I'm gonna go kill something
can I kill something kill kill kill kill
kill kill they probably should have
taken away your weapons kill kill kill
kill kill yeah
all kill kill kill oh that's not kill
that's read later
well we wha in the years following the
end of the Golden Age completing
factions for an Argentine er turned
against one another the insidious
influence of beset itself upon the
sentinel people corrupting its once held
sacred traditions the coliseum wants a
place of honorable combat where
prisoners of the Argento we're tested
for the right to fight in the frontlines
of their army has since been a place for
bloodsport and violation dissent of law
the priests have been caged and even
their merciless executioner used to
enact judgment of their own decree
gladiator wielding an ax Kirstin shield
which in tombs the tormented soul if
it's undiagnosed or remains undefeated
and battle infamous for the many lives
it has claimed well funny about that I
literally can't die I'm too angry to die
so I'm gonna kills ya I'm gonna kill ya
dead hey buds I've seen your ghosts very
helpful mmm
[Music]
you'll make a fine addition to the
frontline streak the demons everywhere
must bring him to us I want to know more
about the others who speaks oh yes your
grace
if sanctum the holy blood is spilled on
these grounds
you will lose our sovereignty here
uh-huh
what
huh what kind of arbitrary rule is that
why would I care you find someone that
could actually hurt me and I'll I'll let
them know what I think of their rules
hey how you doing I'm gonna kill you
all right cool good to know when its
eyes are green to stagger them create an
opening okay you got it hey can i wow
hey what if I Hey
[Music]
hi how you doing oh I love the music
mariette Oh did you kill my dude I was
gonna use that guy oh this is good music
hey bud when you do something oh you
blinking I saw that blink oh hey all
right can you you're being awfully
boring can you do something what was
that
[Music]
okay so I got a delay my reflexes are
too quick when it comes down to the eye
flash
how about I did this is not working I'm
just gonna do this
thank you thank you easy peasy
thank you whoa that was much more
vicious than I remember anything being
[Music]
man my reflexes are too good for you I
can tell there he goes
oh no is your shield gonna go you better
put that shield down my dude it's not
gonna do you any good
oh no right in the eyeball
that's a damn shame Oh looks like it's
just you and me my dude oh no oh no no
you've got no one to defend you with
that shield wider variety spins flail
returns back he's about to strike yeah
okay
what is that a shield so he just has
another shield that's all he has oh yeah
oh yeah bring it on yeah Wankel ooh
how about I give you a face full of this
cuz I know this is good stuff here hello
thank you for getting close Oh what are
you gonna do nothing ah you did it what
is this going on here what are you whoa
hey whoa aah whoa all right fine I see I
see I see yes yes yes Wow hey enough of
that none of that none of that oh my god
what the hell oh I see oh I see sorry
that took me oh that took me way too
long to understand what was happening
now is a bit dumb of me all right but do
you want some of this I got you I got
you I got to okay so right here here
here
[Music]
oh no no no there you go yeah come on
tonight you big big baby you big bubble
blowing baby oh yeah yeah yeah uh-huh
whoops that was a mistake this is such a
silly move
that's very silly that's a little silly
[Music]
no no no you do your spinny thing love
the choir though
do love the choir that's a very nice
let's do this
oh why that was a hit okay we're being
this are we doing this no all right fine
you know I'll do this without oh no you
suck my 1ups now you die okay now you
die no you die womp is that it oh no
it's not over
hey wall boosts that animation seemed a
little silly didn't seem quite as
polished as it could have been for all
the brutality that I've ripped and tared
things before hey that looks fancy that
looks important
nothing will be consumed regardless
well there you go then
well fat lot of good they did glurg
kills on heavy demons will not instantly
charge a blood punch ok cool neat all
right
did that got those that was an odd level
it was oddly designed that one didn't
feel as polished and also it was a slow
level like the other levels before this
and the other game prior he made a point
of like it always put the action first
and I get there trying to tell a story
here and I'm always one for a good story
in a game but more doesn't always mean
better not here's here's my opinion on
the whole thing I'll let they're gonna
talk and they're gonna do two thing and
I'll give my opinion just a second the
carmaker has overloaded your systems
mega has no control over if you wanna :
continue the human race you lie to
protect would survive now I would
resurrect the icon
he will devour us and leave your home
world in ruins
life will be at another world you
brought to extinction
this strong bernal serve as your prison
with no power you can do
okay sure whatever you say oh yeah
oh it's BFG division time yeah I agree I
agree now this is cool this is what I
want yeah [ __ ] come on my ship you come
into my home I don't think so body moves
I don't think so no no no no no Sam you
wait there no no no no no I don't think
so hey there's still some power yes oh I
forgot to have that
you've sought to eradicate from birth
the mission on Sentinel Prime was a
success has been only a Slayers crucible
blade can stop a Titan you must get to
the Sentinel city of Terrace Nevada to
retrieve your crucible before it is too
late without it the Titan cannot be
stopped but I just had that crucible but
if I have that one I'll just go to the
Titan pop that baby out of there go stab
a [ __ ] come back put it back in say hey
Samuel I did it crucible worked funny
about that um okay so yours here is my
thing this game don't get me wrong I
love the game the game is fantastic the
gameplay is super solid the the gameplay
is just like so top level that it's hard
to describe it's so fun to play so fun
this story is slowing it down this story
is doing a disservice to the gameplay
and it's not a big disservice I'm not
saying like it's ruining it I'm not
saying it's making everything bad I
actually kind of like elements of the
story but Salm elements of the story I
feel are over complicating the situation
and confusing the motivation of both the
heroes and the villains because at the
end of the day the villain is very
clearly hell but what is hell they are
defining the people that the Doom Slayer
and not even his people anymore his
people are the humans on earth which
their connection is misconstrued and I
don't know if it's like an alternate
timeline thing they said the TimeWalker
yadda yadda but it's it's confusing the
motivation of the people on our agenda
nor like when were they corrupted the
con maker were they always corrupted
were they always just looking out for
themselves are they still looking out
for the Sentinels who are apparently
still alive whereas like it was my
understanding that the betrayal was so
bad that it let hell win so what is hell
is hell just am unlevel enforcer does
he'll have motivations beyond just
destruction or not because right now it
just seems like they're a tool to be
used and to what end why do they allow
themselves to be used and why is the con
maker have control over them and I'm
sure there's more reasons to it but
very confused right now and worst of all
it confuses the motivation behind the
doom Slayer himself it makes his
character weaker it may seem like it's
making his character stronger yeah he's
always had this motivation and drive to
kill and that's fine by itself and me
saying that you might even be thinking
like oh that's his motivation the last
one but this is different
he had motivation in the last one he
really did this one's only motivation is
like I hate demons they [ __ ] me over
even if it's the original loop like one
day I just started blasting and I've
never stopped since like I can get it
that's motivate that is motivation but
to me that is weaker motivation then
this character who was the best of this
race not like super super human which
apparently this guy was even before he
got his power infusion was the best of
them all was the leader was the one
pointing forwards made a mistake the one
who was the best thought himself
invincible and thought himself right in
all situations had a situation where he
made an impossible decision to save his
son and it backfired in not only the
worst way for himself but everyone
around him and led to the death of his
entire population that was what my
previous understanding of the character
was and the reason that's a stronger
motivation is because if you take a man
who was willing to do anything for his
son and you take away his son there is
no limit to what that man will do to get
revenge
there is only hate inside of him there
is only regret there's only bitterness
and those motivations drive someone
forward and if that is the lesson it
took that's the humbling that's the fall
from grace that the doom Slayer that I
previously knew had if that person then
is given a chance to fight back they are
going to take it and they are never
going to stop and I love that as a
motivation because it was the most pure
hatred a individual could understand for
demons demons are never to be trusted
Hell itself is never to be trusted no
matter how smart they may seem no matter
how beguiling they may be no matter
promises of power they will always
betray you and therefore they should be
killed before they can even utter a word
because that's all they deserve and that
motivation in that power the power is
tempered and leaves the department of
unreality and stops being so
superman-like and starts being like this
power is a burden this power is a curse
he was given the very power that made
Hell itself powerful and is using it
against them in a never-ending quest of
death and destruction and I think that
is a fantastic very pure clear character
the character they had in that Coliseum
in that flashback with the rip tear rip
and tear it just seems corny it
unfortunately seems corny and at no
point did the doom guy ever seem corny
even though he was given his little doll
a fist bump that was awesome that was so
cool it was just a really nice moment
but when it comes down to that if that's
who this guy is and he's just someone
that's like rip and tear rip and tear
that's like a lot of battle cry it's
it's weird
it was weird in the comic I'm not saying
this is the worst way that you could
take this story and it's fine if this is
this is what they chose this is what
they chose and I respect that and I
honor that but in my personal opinion I
feel like it weakens the character and
weakens the motivation because now all
this guy has is I don't trust those
demons they have never convinced me
they've never tempted me they've never
tricked me
I just know to kill him that's what I
know and that's fine but that doesn't
tell me that this person will for all
time kill demons that tells me that
eventually this guy will peter out
because his motivation isn't so pure
it's strong and his will is definitely
strong and you can write in his will was
strong and that's fine you can write
that and then it's true and it is but
it's hard to believe when there's
nothing backing it up like the worst
mistake a single person could ever make
and you can bet that that person that
I'm describing would never make that
mistake ever again and it doesn't make
him weaker because they made a mistake
it makes him human anyway
I want to kill something I want to kill
something real bad what am i killing
whatever killing hey what's up this is
the resistance Network broadcasting live
from inside the Arctic safe zone there
was a slayer sighting on Phobos
eyewitness reports say that he was
spotted inside a command center and then
proceeded to fight his way through the
mortally challenged and onto the deck of
the BFG 10k this can't be confirmed but
many believe it was the Slayer himself
who destroyed Mars in an attempt to stop
the challenged from further advancing
their position on earth we will post
more information as it comes in this is
an arc broadcast I didn't necessarily
destroy Mars I kind of just blew a big
hole in it which again very very cool
move like if you really think about it
but however you don't have anything to
say about how the demonic consumption of
Earth has been stopped
also why just these three dudes these
three dudes are the only thing
responsible for the demonic invasion of
Earth that's intense
anyway enough lore talk let's get to why
we're here which is the killing and the
dead did the deal and in the killing I
love the red the Red's nice the Red's
real nice I have six Sentinel batteries
should I use those for any reason and
should I be concerned that there might
be other demons somewhere else in my
base or is this all chill are we all
good now we all we all good and I gotta
drop my unmei querque in there uh yeah
only one more and then I'm I'm gonna
pull you out and I'm gonna shoot some
stuff five of six you know almost there
Madhu's almost there I guess I could go
ahead and who do I have anything that
could use another mod The BFG has no
other things I mean not really I don't
really need it do I need the suit points
I'll do this
sure yeah that way I get to granades all
right cool let's just get out there and
let's start killing it I want to kill
something so bad it's been so long I'm
killed deprived my burning rage in my
yearning for death and blood it just
God's knowing at me oh wait is this
where I this is where I played this so
apparently this is difficult I am a
freshly born baby wandering into this
literally going into hell
you're sending a baby in now with the
death of a priest the blood ritual has
been broken the con maker desperate for
a way to consume earth is attempting to
resurrect the icon of sin under her
command
only the Slayers crucible blade can stop
the icon to retrieve it you must journey
back into your past to the city of
Terezin Abad where your legend began ok
[Music]
ting well now I know what's what's
facing me I know what's waiting for me
over here huh buddy
oh boy more lore yeah let's read it tera
Samba city the crowning jewel of the
argent dinner for centuries that served
as the spiritual heart of the artists
I'd be home to the royal family in the
center of political power no expensive
love I read it before I read it again oh
yeah give me the music give me the music
mmm give me the music the siren calls
I'm if I can't if I'm gonna die what a
fall off theater yes give me the music I
don't need anything from you sir sir
ma'am
ma'am sir yeah hey what are you doing
there bones yes
hey get out of my way what are you doing
oh my god
down what happened to me I've really
changed still nice hey stop it stop it
Jay zooms yeah redonkulous well it looks
like I gotta go toe to toe with someone
by the name of Marathi are you doing a
you're on the different side I remember
you being on quite the other side come
here yeah what are you gonna do oh oh no
looks like you suck I walked into that
one
alright okay let me hang on I gotta get
wet wow that was wrong hey sorry I
goofed
I goofed many a thing out of my way I
didn't go anywhere
yeah oh my god give me that kill sorry
ma'am
okay you and me you me you me you and me
you me yeah what you gonna do what you
gonna do nothing that's why I thought
god you suck and I mean you're bad
you're not like aggravating me or
anything you're just bad god I can read
you like a book you want one of these
so I got a business figure with this
dude
come on you yes oh there you go there
you go my dude the great city of chars
[Music]
the arrival of the Slayer see that's a
little different than just the Slayer
was here
I missed a secret already oh no I see
where it is oh yes I see you yeah BFG
division I love it that's my favorite
song it's so badass it is so heavy oh I
love it okay did I miss anything else
looks like a big no I know where to go
here thank you
uh-huh thank you hey cheers bud I know
that we're not on good terms right now
because for some reason you care that I
killed the priest which is very weird
that you would even let me in the first
place because you knew what I was gonna
do like all of you had to have known
what I was all about I was gonna kill
that dude real hard and there was like
nothing you could have done to stop me
he was going to happen oh let's do this
let's do this baby where's this I know
there's an arch file that's gonna spawn
here I know it I sense it my amazing
skills really uh oh yeah he's on he's on
he's on where is he Oh everything going
fast
good god oh my goodness okay there
should have been whoa there's an arch
file that's hitting me so where is it oh
my god okay you guys kind of suck
all right you are not some I can saw but
you are God let me Adam just the way
that they get stuck up and everything
where is the oh there you are oh I see
you okay alright okay okay okay okay
moving ky slow moving real slow we're
missiles incoming hey how you doing
buddy hey man shouldn't have been near
that shield didn't really help you much
you know actually I'm gonna do some a
bit beefier Oh interesting interesting
interesting interesting oh you so why
don't I don't have any more Oh give me
that I need that I need oh well god
those those ones with like the super
rings are the worst okay well that was
poor showing knows is that is poor
showing
okay so god oh my god just getting stuck
on people why is that a thing why is it
that you can get stuck that's so stupid
that's so incredibly soon where is you
where is this dude oh I shouldn't have
grabbed that there oh he's there still
alright let me just hear I'm gonna do
something drastic
the game didn't like me doing that the
game just crashed oh there's an update
to the game man the game did not like
that no the game did not like that at
all
I came heard me talking [ __ ] about the
story okay let's try this once more time
alright this time I'm going right for
him wherever he's going to spawn
whenever he decides haha interesting
okay so he spawns somewhere else oh boy
where is he
oh no where is he I don't like this
where is he where is he where the Frick
oh there you are
alright cool good I'm gonna do this to
you
there we go oh no oh that is unfortunate
for you and you to that place to walk
into that one oh just a little late on
that shield and kaboom that's not the
right thing what is that
Oh cuz I have no ammo in that one oh of
course
all right easy peasy point
[Music]
there's no need to be pissy at me I'm
not the one who stole the crucible and
tried the Gouda whole argent thing if I
remember correctly that was you I was a
whole lot of you buddy I was a whole lot
of you excuse me while I puts this
special button those behind this thing
the whole time because they invented it
that way all right so there's bound to
be men you seek what is that know hey
boo spot and I burst a bet well that's
mine now I think that might be a mastery
token yes it is oh good
what do I have I got this thing might as
well use it bring it on
who wants to die you do you do I know
you do I know you do I know you do I
know you do I know you do I'm gonna die
speaking of dying holy crap hey hey that
shouldn't hit me oh I have no ammo wait
wait no wait wait wait wait hang on wait
yeah wait yeah I have no ammo what am I
supposed to do if I have no ammo what if
I what do I do I got no ammo
dude I got no ammo this is absurd i-i've
never had no ammo like this before you
know all of my guns I got no ammo you
really the situation absolutely dick
diddly on all ammo all right let's try
this again
point
oh okay know that whoa that's a lot of
granado's
oh well trick is not to stand there and
just eat those so I know the trick now
Oh what stuff what do you suck so much
mana now I got no health oh I'll come
back for you then I'll come back for you
I got still push the button god this is
this is upside this is upside then
alright so there's something here I'm
just gonna go through what is happening
there my hatred for the demons because
of all the things they did to me this is
for them this is for Greg and Steve BAM
that was for Roger and I need to go back
because I left many things behind I
think I think yeah there's something
over there Sentinel battery was low ow
ow ow there goes all the health I just
bought back alright now this time it's
gonna be different maybe oh gods my [ __ ]
you dick lord I don't have time for that
oh come on don't miss
how the Frick did I get hurt wait what
oh my god what am i sweat and my stuck
oh you kidding me no what the hell it
didn't pick up the armor the drop down
and just kill me screw that let's be the
noise okay the game definitely heard me
talking we're a might know I gotta go uh
Frick oh and all the health I just had
is gone goddamn it this is really
annoying
this is supremely annoying oh god damn
it I'll just go back at the end of the
level when I get fast travel that's what
I'll do I'll do that okay all right I'm
moving forward history of the Sentinels
oh you know they seem to have been able
to kill Titans pretty good with the
coming of the Slayer the night sentinels
took the campaign deeper into the
heartland of demons than ever before
mighty Outlands were brought forth
tearing paths through the hordes of hell
alongside the Slayer in his army the
high priest under the guidance of the
mother God had found means to gain entry
to the innermost regions of the demon
world and with the diegs presence new
gates could be opened our war machines
were unstoppable wrought with maker
technology enhanced by the very essence
of our enemies hurled against us as our
armies drove deeper and deeper into the
blood-drenched territory of the demons
countless victories were assured with
the power of the Slayer for with the
alpha into factor at the fore of our
pack we brought certain doom to our foes
and though our hearts were pure and our
purpose righteous unbeknownst to the
fighters of argenta in our wake and
under the veil of secrecy the mother God
had set a priest to build vast factories
upon the heathens land that she might
gather the essence for further
development how this deception began we
would not know for our focus remained on
the hordes of the underworld why then
would we stoop so low as to consider our
mother god of betraying our covenant the
Kahn maker did not seem at ease with the
unforeseen rise of our Slayer and the
Seraphim who had
the destroyer and secret soon vanished
from her back
perhaps exiled for his heresy our
legions rose unfettered under the
unquenchable rage of the doomed Slayer
and his design led the Kahn make earn a
profit in his endorsement it soon became
known that the Slayer was the makers god
machine a holy relic reborn sent to
bring the makers word to the wicked and
to smite those who would seek to harm
all who followed the path to earth ak
with the Slayer unwittingly cleaving a
path for her the mother God's siphoned
the essence processing it beyond our
knowledge into the fuel that would come
to be known as Arjun energy the Slayer
cared not for polity he took no interest
in the workings of our people but said
his task only on his desire the
destruction of the demons and their
world he no longer spoke for reasons
unknown though it was understood that he
still possessed the ability offering
only guttural Hef's Avenger as he
inflicted pain upon his enemies for
years he marched with the Knights
sentinels
through the fires of the demon lands and
every returned to our homeworld found
much changed in order to know should any
blame be a portion to the Sentinels it
is this in our fervor we were a
negligent of our people and did not see
the rising tide of evil our crusade and
power we knew only the enemy laid before
us and the wealth of our gent at our
backs and did not pause to seek the cost
and method of this progress oh okay this
is Benny lor heavy episode very lor
heavy and that's fine I've said my piece
about the lore I've said it and that'll
be the only time that I talk about it
until maybe the very end of the game so
take that for what it is I would love to
know your opinion on it but remember
this is the creator of the game's story
as much as I would have
in some things differently that doesn't
mean that my opinion has very much value
in terms of this story and a lot of you
might disagree with me and that's fine
too there is no reason to the animosity
adult towards the developers at all for
any reason because this is their story
and to be perfectly honest the game is
still fantastic it's glorious
it's awesome I love it the gameplay is
super fun I find some things to be
frustrating sometimes because sometimes
the game can't be perfect at all times
and sometimes it's my own failure so
that is what it is so thank you
everybody so much for watching I'm still
excited to continue this I'm having a
ton of fun it's just that this episode
happened to be killing light so I'm
going to get back to that so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always and we'll see you in the next
video bye bye
[Music]